Cào thông tin từ bán phòng nghiên cứu 2 quanh, hạn đối tông khu chủ của Mỹ của ông khoảng 17 triếng
Chuyếu là lớp Alibot, đưa trưng bị hệ thống ra đa hiện đại và bệ phóng thẳng đứng
có thể thực hiện nhiều nhận vụ từ phòng không tấn công mạnh nước đến chống tòng em
có tổ này liên tổn đứng năng tấp công nghệ và thủy thủy đoàn đủ hình luệ bài bản
Thông qua có hoàn đậm chình 2 quanh cầu, tạo lời thế vượt tròi bình năng lực tác chiến
Chúc khi đó 2 quanh Trung Quốc lên tăng tâm mừng giống hạn đối
Từ 2 mì tạo năng hạn hình không trong lệ 3,5 mì 2 tạo năng hạn hình không trai bà
Nhưng chứ được tiếp kể hiện đại và có nước lực tránh trình tiếp với tổ Mỹ
Ý tìm lấn của Trung Quốc nằm ở tốc độ đón cầu của Kuy Mu Sần Sốt
Tuy nhiên, kinh nghiệm tác chiến và chiến khai kính chiến của thủy thủ đoàn vẫn còn hạn chế
Hẹn tại đi vẫn sẵn đầu với Trung tổng cầu
Thế khởi tổ xin bài và phạm đi hoàn độc toàn cầu
Trung Quốc chùi yếu tập trung cho khu vực những sự ra tánh nhân chống về số lượng và năng ở tên lượng
Đăng khiến khẩn trên trên bệnh trường đến gài gát và khó đoán Trung Quốc tổy tối